the right.
I've already given you my view about so-called
council culture in the last segment and why
Republicans are now doing this.
They have no policy.
They've lost everything in the last two years.
House, Senate, White House.
Joe Biden is the most popular first month
president in twenty eight years.
They are desperate and they want to be the
perpetual, unending victims.
Now let's take a tour through some of the
funniest Cancio culture clips and claims from
the last day or two, because they now it's
sort of like a it's like a hyena who sends
who smells blood.
The hyena notices the gazelle is a little
slow on its feet, that the right rear hoof
gazelles have hooves.
I think they do that right rear hoof looks
a little bit not right.
And so they say the hyenas now is our opportunity.
Now is our opportunity.
And that's what the right is doing.
Congressman Jim Jordan is now calling for
congressional hearings, uncancel culture.
He sent a letter yesterday to Congressman
Jerry Nadler, who runs the House Judiciary
Committee, saying that council culture is
so dangerous, so pernicious, such an existential
threat that if it goes unchallenged, every
viewpoint and idea could be canceled.
And Jim Jordan wants hearings.
That's Jim Jordan this morning on Fox and
Friends.
Donald Trump Jr. went on a council culture
rant which the Fox and Friends hosts seemed
to love at first.
But then you'll hear Brian Kilmeade sort of
try to give Don Jr. the wrap up.
Take a look at this.
There's this cancel culture, trying to cancel
Dr Seuss now.
How far are they going to take this?
There's no place that they won't go, Ainslee.
There's no place they won't go.
This week alone, they canceled Mr. Potato
Head.
You know, this week alone, they canceled the
Muppets.
You know, they're canceling Dr. Seuss for
reading programs.
I mean, these are books.
I literally know the cat in the hat by heart
without the book there, because I read it
so many times to my children.
These things are not racist.
You have Oreo cookie chiming in on trans rights.
I mean, what is going on?
I have no idea.
Absolutely insane.
Just keep reading our minds and we're encouraging
it, you know, by allowing it.
You saw, you know, the job goes after CPAC
because the stage apparently had Nazi symbolism
because these guys are so obsessed with trying
to create any link to that, which it looked
like he was doing a good job.
But in twenty four hours they to cave to the
WOAK mob.
Don, thanks.
Everything is cancelation.
And notice that each of those things that
Don Jr. mentions are totally unrelated.
The stage at CPAC looked like a Nazi emblem,
but OK, well, that's totally separate from
reading material decisions made in schools,
and that's unrelated to the decisions made
by private companies about the products they
want to put out.
Now they want you to think it's all part of
the same liberal plot and culture.
It's a sort of Gish Gallop conspiratorial
thinking.
You mentioned 10 things.
It's not totally clear if they're related,
but if it sort of sounds like they are, the
audience hears it and goes, wow, that's quite
a list of stuff.
But you have to separate it out and go through
it piece by piece.
Here's another clip from this morning's Fox
and Friends.
They they truly seem to have nothing to talk
about other than this, talking about more
council culture.
It is March 2nd.
It is read across America day.
It is also Dr. Seuss, his birthday and traditionally
in our country, we celebrate read across America
on his birthday because we all grew up reading
his books and loved them.
But Biden is there is a proclamation claiming
that this is read across America day, but
he is leaving out the mention of Dr. Seuss
because of this one county, Loudoun County,
in Virginia.
And they are saying that it's controversial
and they want to cancel Dr Seuss.
Yeah, they the researchers surveyed 50 Dr.
Seuss books and concluded the other two thousand
two hundred and forty identified human characters.
There are 435 characters of color representing
two percent of the total human population
of the forty five characters, forty three
exhibited behaviors and appearances that align
with harmful and stereotypical Orient Oriental
tropes.
So that's Brian Kilmeade kind of fabricated
outrage voice.
And you know that, by the way, when Fox News
is pretending to care about literature, you
know, it's a fabricated issue since literature
is not a top issue for Fox News viewers unless
it plays into some other sociocultural outrage
that they want to generate.
We know literature is not high on the list
of priorities for Fox News viewers, here's
another example from a few days ago.
This is from the Tucker Carlson propaganda
program where a lawyer named Harmeet Dhillon
told Tucker that the left is trying to console
women.
I mean, I appreciate your coming on tonight.
So the Equality Act, everything is Orwell.
Is that is this about equality?
It would better be named the Women's Cancelation
Act because it looks like cancer culture has
finally come for the female gender.
Tucker, what we're seeing in this act is basically
a denial of science.
And this is the flat earth was taking control
of the government and using those levers of
power to elevate the rights of transgender
women, met people who are born as men over
the rights of biological women.
And it's not just conservatives who are concerned
about this, Tucker.
So there, again, is the raising of the issue
of trans women in sports.
I won't go into that in detail now because
I've done two or three segments about that
over the last couple of weeks.
If you're curious about my thoughts on that,
you can find those clips.
But in short, the fact that individually we
can find we can find instances where we need
to sort of think through what makes sense
in certain sporting situations, athletic situations,
pretending that this is the issue on the forefront
of American culture and and society is another
one of these fabricated outrage issues from
the right Trump even jumping on board.
Remember, Trump brought up cancel culture
during that bizarre 90 minute speech at CPAC,
which Trump himself even seemed bored with.
Take a look at this.
And in particular, we reject Tanso culture.
So remember how this all works, you and I,
hopefully, if you're like me, you have a diverse
set of news sources, you're not just paying
attention to the news, but you're also reading
history and and reading philosophy and other
sorts of nonfiction.
And you sort of have a broad view of what's
going on in the world.
You follow some international news, etc.
If you only watch Fox News and watched CPAC
and listen to what the former president, Donald
Trump says, you would be under the impression
that the issues plague plaguing America right
now.
Are trans women and sports conservatives getting
suspended on Twitter, potato head, Dr. Seuss
and of course, fighting communism rather than
the pandemic inequality economics, the covid
relief bill, getting people vaccinated, dealing
with the climate, fixing money in politics,
getting everybody health care.
That's how it works.
And we know it works because you go to CPAC
and you interview random people.
This is the stuff that the attendees are talking
about.
We're against socialism and communism.
So we're mad about Joe Biden being here, but
there's no risk of communism or socialism
in the United States.
So it does work.
And unfortunately, it's hard to even have
a shot at deprogramming someone if you can't
even get them out of an echo chamber where
these are the issues that are reinforced as
the major issues facing the country.
So it's an uphill battle.
It's clear, as I as I said earlier, with my
hyena gazelle analogy, they smell blood.
They see they see the opportunity here to
strike on this issue of council culture and
they plan to strike and strike and strike,
to quote the great Paula White.
We will have more coverage of this on our
Instagram.
Find us at David Pakman show and find me on
Instagram at David Pakman as well.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com